I wish to go on a date with Mila Kunis
if you so
sure shuts
debt ripes dream to date his wife Mila
Kunis I have a really great husband I
really do the 70s Show star is
supporting the comedian by helping
announce his first world tour
problematic I am Eugenie I'm Ben
summonsed and now it's time to Grant you
a wish you sure you're a genie because
you look more like Ashton Kutcher uh
when you become a genie you get to Grant
one wish and mine was to look like
Ashton Kutcher why would you want to do
that
it was the early 2000s and it seemed
like what look this isn't about me this
is about you so what's your question
Matt goes on to make his wish which is
very personal to Ashton I wish to go on
a date with Mila Kunis if you saw
oh yep that's his wife popping in right
before she snapped Away by her hubby no
oh it's not gonna happen all right I'm
she's very happily married and I'm
pretty sure she's not into problematic
voice okay I think it's funny well Matt
seems to have fans in Mila and Ashton
and tons of people on social media too
introverted despite this job like I'm
pretty introverted the comic who's known
for sharing clips from his stand-ups has
over 13 million followers on Tick Tock
and 3.7 million on Instagram but before
becoming an internet sensation Matt got
his big break on MTV's wild 'n out when
he was 19 years old this is my brother
and he's never on time the only reason
she's with him cause he's got Drake's
hairline he went on to produce comedy
specials over the years oh man
wow some of y'all didn't stand
you were unsure I get it sorry I'll earn
it that's okay you guys uh
ready to be offended and in 2019 Matt
appeared on NBC's bring the funny I'm
dating right now because Chrissy doesn't
know what she's doing with her life yeah
and remember when he tried to romance
Chrissy Teigen Matt this has to stop
but thought we had a good thing the
talking
concentrating on me the flirting it's
it's too much it's
not I can't do this I mean the
characters that we've seen on this stage
have just been a treat and now Matt's
hitting stages worldwide on his tour
that's one wish Ashton's able to Grant I
wish for a world tour bigger than
anything I could have ever dreamed of
and I want it full sold out with people
from across the world who just want to
come out have a good time and laugh
prepare yourself
for the tour of a lifetime your wish
is my command go
[Music]